good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday happy day
three and final day
of be on the tea sad ben on the toast
we're gonna make it a good one though we
have a lot to talk about today we have
so much catching up to do we do and how
are you feeling this morning how was
your weekend i'm feeling good just like
i'm a little under the weather don't
worry it's not the vid but so in case
you like hear me like
it's not like my normal well like i need
an allergy pill it's like i could sneeze
considering we spend so much time with
claudia we know that
is very common for you that's what i'm
saying it's not the common
it's
not it's not the common one it's
different actually that one she refuses
to acknowledge that it completely goes
away with one single zyrtec okay she
yeah she doesn't acknowledge that she
says it does come in waves but i mean we
all know you you're very
yeah when i forget to take my zyrtec
okay but this is i'm sorry that i am an
allergic human being and nobody has
any sympathy for my allergies well get
your like get your business done no you
know i i don't handle your business did
i clear on thursday or friday clear any
i don't know but i do think that we
might be triggering people by starting
out this episode with so many bodily
function noises okay sorry so we're
gonna pivot i hope you feel better soon
glad to hear it's not the vid take care
of yourself
and we're gonna get into today's show
because we have a lot to discuss not
only do we have the fast five stories
that are robust
but you and i did a little homework last
night we brought back toast movie of the
week and we watched the brittany murphy
documentary on hbo max called what
happened brittany murphy and i'm so glad
that we did i got so much out of it it
wasn't a story that i really kept up
with much when it was going down because
like we were in high school so
i learned so much and i have a lot of
thoughts so i look forward to talking
about them and then we both watched the
season premiere of curblast we did so
we're going to talk about that too lots
of synergistic
show watching yes so lots of thoughts to
be shared i also spent the weekend
watching succession do you watch that
show
it was my third time trying to start
watching it the first two times i just
could not get into it i was like these
people are
not
my sort of people uh but then i was like
you know what everybody likes it it's so
acclaimed i have really nothing better
to do the bar is lower let's give it
another shot and so now i'm totally into
it i'm on the last episode of season two
right now
and it's good it's not like my favorite
show and i'm not really like obsessed
with anyone but it's pretty smart so
maybe i'll start watching it yeah i
think you would like it yeah i think
it's just like it's good quality you
know
it's just there's something about it
that's just not
my cup of tea but i'm but i'm still
enjoying it
all right we'll see if i ever have a
day where i need something fair weekend
yeah
so what'd you get into this weekend
anything good
um let's see
lots of bars bar hopping whoa
lots of dinners ate a lot
good
what i do every time claudia is gone i
see my friends we go to dinner we go to
a bar
i come home i wake up the house is messy
i clean it before she comes home and
that's it
so you've been living with your mess do
you miss claudia i've been living with
my mess just terribly well she comes
home today and
she's almost home
we did we did a very very good job of
facetiming even though she was in rome
so we had some good ketchup catch-up
time
um and she was able to catch up with
theo as well yeah but she had her did
she show everybody the italian crunch
that she frightened well she showed me
but i didn't i don't know if she posted
a terror story but she did meet italian
theo
romeo
and he was cute he was terrified though
yeah
now we have to post that picture just
because i think everyone will find it
really funny she must have startled him
and he just his face looks so spooked
yeah it's a great great photo yeah it
was it was wonderful trying to think
what else i did this weekend i golfed on
friday as you guys know we do played
okay it wasn't like it wasn't my best
uh did some work on saturday you know i
find this may be an unpopular opinion if
you can do like two or three hours of
work on saturday it really makes your
monday significantly nicer well i did
that so much less pressure i did that
yesterday actually actually that's a
great segue to let you know that there's
a new vlog up on our patreon i finally
filmed my favorite amazon finds claudia
had done hers and so i did like i think
it's about like 20 items that i've
gotten from amazon over the last year
that i just i can't live without like
gadgets gizmos remedies migraine relief
like cooking stuff
and i think it's really helpful like i
literally use all those products every
single day so
head over to
patreon.comtoast to check it out cool
yeah that's a cool idea yeah so i uh
yesterday i did a little bit of work so
that had me feeling productive because
on saturday i was just such a lump on a
log and it just gives me a pit like when
i'm
so
lazy and when you're that lazy it's
sometimes very difficult to become not
lazy i know and then but you're also
like okay so saturday for example i was
having just a totally indulgent day but
i had like all these things i knew that
i needed to do so it was ruining my
indulgence for sure if i had just done
it then i could have enjoyed my day of
peace done the smallest thing yeah i
literally i said to myself the entire
weekend
clean the dining room table
clean the dining room table and then
finally last night i cleaned it but to
that point if i had just cleaned it on
friday he would have had him i wouldn't
have felt like that free or weekend i
would have instead i was basically in
chains yeah i was in mental chains it's
true i mean i had like all the like some
fun fact about me is i don't open my
packages when they come they just all
sit by the door make sense and pile up
and so on sunday i finally went through
all of them and like that felt really
productive as well so yesterday was the
productive day saturday was the chill
day but all of those times were spent
with brew
having just a ball you and brew edible
me and brew had a ball this weekend he
was extra extra cute this weekend it was
crazy cutie it was so crazy and he hung
out with his best friend heating pad oh
my god heating cab
he loves the heating pad i mean who
wouldn't who wouldn't eating pads are
wonderful they are he and i like
literally fight over it i mean and i did
get a second one because it's like just
get one for me
no and he peed on it that one so he was
like i don't want this one wow i want
that one he was angry he was angry
so he just wants to share with me and
wow that's crazy isn't that crazy that
is
very intentional
very intentional so i guess we should
get into everything because we have so
much to talk about and i know you're a
busy man i don't want to take up too
much of your time sure so let's launch
right into the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
beat the crunch did you beat the crouch
we'll only we'll find out when i beat it
it was beaten
sure jan it was beaten sure
well just want to let you know today's
episode is brought to you by current
current is a technology company that
lets you manage your money on your phone
current believes banking should be more
accessible and affordable no surprises
no minimum balances current's easy to
use app and debit card gives you
flexibility freedom and faster access to
your money with benefits like earning
points when you swipe with your debit
card at eligible merchants redeemable
for cash back no fees on over 40 000 in
network all point atms in the us helpful
spending insights and notifications to
track where and when you're spending
easy to create savings goals including
ability to round up purchases to save
extra change
so
we are partnering with current we left
you know last week but don't forget that
we're partnering with current to give
away one thousand dollars to our
listeners that's right current is going
to give away 250 to four listeners of
our show all you have to do is download
the current app and enter our code toast
during a sign up for a chance to win
remember that's code toast during sign
up the giveaway will end november 10th
2021 so sign up now before it's too late
remember
remember download the current app sign
up in less than two minutes and enter
code toast for a chance to win visit
current.com toast for full terms and
conditions
great now let's get into the first story
which is some breaking news this morning
that you actually shared with me you
really have your
pulse on the fashion industry
kim kardashian announces a skim's ex
fendi ready to wear collection
from the comfort of your bedroom to the
runway and back kim kardashian west's
shapewear and lingerie brand skims is
releasing a special collaboration with
italian fashion house fendi she
announced in an interview with wall
street journal magazine on monday ahead
of the publication's upcoming innovator
awards
the skim sex bendy ready to wear
collection will launch on november 9th
and feature form-fitting dresses and
tops that start at 950
leggings will retail for 1 100 and the
collection also features two thousand
nine hundred and fifty dollar puffer
jacket just in time for winter of course
skim signature underwear shapewear and
hoisery hosiery hosiery hosiery we'll
also get a fendi revamp printed with the
collaboration logo the collection will
also feature swimsuits also in the logo
print and a leather wrap dress and eight
shades selling for four thousand two
hundred dollars okay so much to break
down here first of all this is
the collaboration like i could only
dream about skims
kim love bendy love then the looks that
they put forth are everything they
incorporate the skims branding and fendi
and then we come to find out that the
price point is more reflective of
fendi's prices than skims which you know
is a bit i was hoping for it was you
know skims slapped with some f's on it
it makes sense though yeah and you're
such a premium brand like you really
can't like fendi you really can't
just discount your price for a collab
but no but it's been it's done a lot
like when bomban did h m or like
moschino like a lot of
of the top fashion brands do partner
with um
like more affordable brands and they
make their styles and just like you know
in the
vein of
h m interesting that's a good call so i
thought maybe this would be like that
but
it's like this instead but i mean also
so i guess it's being made with like
fendi materials products probably not
no they're probably just like a nice
margin
i don't know i think i wonder how those
deals are structured i mean if there's
leather in the collection like that's
the leather's expensive leather is
expensive
i mean the
some of the pieces that are in the
promotion picture so far are really so
sickening yeah they're cool they're
really it's really well designed like
even the tights in this picture of kim
like they say fendi and skims on them so
everyone will know like you got the
collection you logged on november 9th at
6 am and you got it of course i'm gonna
try for some things i need to take a
look at everything that's
being put forward i want to just get
like one thing do you think that
anything will be
like really great on like stockx like is
this stuff that will be
available for resale at a
higher price yes because i think
they're definitely not making so much so
yeah i think a lot of people are going
to buy it up and try and resell it for
sure and they will be sold for even more
so it's really an investment
i will be making an investment
i hope i mean i have to
you know log on and do the whole
set and alarm thing but fendi x skims is
worth it i mean zach is the king of that
so you should just have him do that he
is he always is like scheduling drops
he's on for the drop he's on for the
drop yep so that's true maybe he can
help me with some pointers
but this is really exciting i had heard
some whispers about a collaboration like
this happening
kim's been like doing a lot with fendi
and people had said something like this
might be coming so
it's really cool it's a really big
moment for schemes she's had a lot of
big moments recently the team usa
stuff so skims is just
doing doing it all it's a cool brand
skims yeah you ever wear squad loves it
no i don't do they make stuff for men
no
no
i like all now yeah i mean what do i
wear i don't i don't know you asked me
that as if there was something actually
didn't when claudia got a pr package you
did put something on oh i did but like
so that was more but there was more of a
you have worn skin that was more not as
dumb a question as i thought i guess
that's true yeah i did put them on but
no there really is nothing for me
unfortunately unfortunately that being
said maybe they do another collab with
uh fendi men
spritz oh
just putting it out there just in case
just in case they want to maybe make a
koozie right now i'm going through kim's
pictures of all the designs so
everything looks honestly so sick this
leotard looks amazing
this
jacket this puffer jacket i guess that's
the one that's 20. jacket's sick but
that's a fendi jacket right but that's
okay so it's spendy no i get it it's
just that's not a skim's fendi jacket
that's bendy jacket no but it says spend
the end schemes like they're the
pattern
like i get it but it's fendy's pattern
no but it also says skim's look let me
see look at that one that's the pattern
that they're using for this
collab
you see the skins in between the fendi
they do
and like
wouldn't you like it more if it just
said
like you know what i mean it's a little
crowded one might like it more but cons
like me personally to have represent kim
and fendi at the same time
i am definitely
setting an alarm good luck everyone out
there you know may the best
shopper win we'll see you on november
9th you know what you should do you
should get like an extra piece or
something and do a crazy giveaway
that would be cool
just fine sure thanks i'm sure that you
don't want to but
yeah i just want the piece because i
would wear it things are meant to be
worn cool
are you ready for our next story really
sweet news i i love sweet news i love
sweet news too paul walker's daughter
meadow is married and she was walked
down the aisle
by paul's former co-star vince diesel of
fast and furious
sorry
like who
sorry sometimes i say people's names
wrong
especially on the show like
totally
innocent like i just i just thought that
might have been his full name
like maybe
like maybe
the n is short for
vince i just
i thought you were reading his full name
that's the only reason i corrected you
i'm literally dying no i mean vin might
be short for vince
but
that's not his name it's probably short
for vincent okay so then vince too no
but
that's really like
like there's a lot of instances of like
ben affleck i can't like say his
last name i always say like aflac i
understand but vince diesel is is a new
one
but anyways not to take away from the
really sweet news which is that
he walked her down the aisle and the
internet was just was
cooing
it's a beautiful story
are you a fast and furious fan
i've seen them the early ones
are pretty good
i am not a fan of any
sort of move it's not a trilogy any
movie no it's like seven what do you
what do you call when it's more than
three just a
series series okay that works well
really to dig deep in the brain for the
word series um i'm not a fan of any
series that doesn't know when it should
end
but have you do you see the most recent
fast and furious did it end
no but like was it good no i'm saying i
don't want to anymore i don't want to i
don't want there to be fast and furious
movies okay i get that there are a lot
of die hard fans yeah i guess i'm
personally just not one of them yeah i
do love vin diesel though yeah in his
academy award-winning performance in the
pacifier
that was just
what a wonderful movie i'm trying to
think what else i like him in
let me go back to his imdb
and i'm sure if one asked him what his
least favorite movie was it would be the
pacifier you never know
no that's such a fun movie it is okay he
was in guardians of the galaxy okay
he's in avatar two and three which is
coming out in 2024.
i don't yeah i don't really know a lot
of these movies so i don't know which
ones are like the big ones sorry
avengers
yeah sure did you see that that it did i
didn't even
saving private ryan
big big you know
has he been in no movies
he's like i thought he was a movie
there were a lot of movies on the list
but none that i that i were worth like
shouting out because i don't know them
so look like there's a lot of movies
here
that's all the movies what are they let
me see let me hold for a second okay let
me just peruse and see if there's
they're all like action movies
he's a very action-packed guy yeah lots
of action
lots of action
okay
all right time to move on no i'm just i
think we the real story is that
vin diesel is just not that big of a
movie streamer yeah i in the end of the
day after he's really shifting through
his films it's really just fascinating
furious in the pacifier agreed so i'm
sure he feels proud of pacifier actually
she should yeah probably made a ton of
money
but that is a lovely story you know when
it is co-workers
help
friends friends it's a lovely story it's
a lovely story you love to see it okay
our next story is a bit of an update
from a story from last week about alec
baldwin we're getting some new
information about what was happening on
the set of the film rush and a worker in
charge of alec baldwin's prop gun was a
replacement hire amid onset chaos and
safety concerns so the prop master who
handled the gun that killed the
cinematographer on alec baldwin's film
rust was just brought in amid a protest
over conditions on the set the post has
learned the unidentified employee was
hired to replace someone else amid chaos
on the set according to a source
involved with the movie another source
briefed on the situation told the post
that a crew of workers had walked off
the film set at the bonanza creek ranch
near santa fe new mexico on thursday
morning over what they alleged were poor
safety protocols before alec fired the
gun later that day
the union for the workers who walked off
the set claimed the prop gun had a live
round in it when it discharged and
killed director photography helena
hutchins and injured director joel souza
the prop gun also misfired twice on
saturday and once during the previous
week the la times reported citing a
knowledgeable crew member who told the
paper that there was a serious lack of
safety meetings on this set
um wow
i mean
this story just gets
wilder and more tragic and now like
seeing that there were concerns over
safety you know this
the people left the set over this like
there were text messages that were sent
that they have that like show that
people were aware that this was like not
an unsafe situation
it just
it's really awful is this a low budget
film i don't know
i don't know i can't imagine alec
baldwin's in many low-budget films i
don't know at this point right i don't
know the budget of this it just doesn't
make any sense that
you would hire a random prop master that
handles your gun
and not check if it's loaded if it's a
new person and a new gun
well like i was reading i don't know if
it's in there but like apparently
that same gun
was used for target practice yeah so
that was another article that i just
pulled up that the shooting the the gun
clearly that gun is not a prop gun yeah
that's a gun yeah which is being used by
a prop master that they randomly just
brought in that day and didn't bother to
ask him if his gun was real or a prop
right because also they brought in that
day because the other prop masters had
walked off over concerns when we were
talking on friday we just assumed that
this was a prop gun with prop books and
that something went awry
but
this was a real gun a live gun which is
so weird yeah and so unnecessary like
it's a movie yeah
it's
weird and terrible story yeah so
we'll keep you people now the question
is and i i don't know the answer
is there was there any foul players it's
just 100 negligence
it seems like there's a theme of
negligence because the people walked off
and then they were replaced
but like
i think there might be some foul play
it's too strange it is really strange
very weird story
yeah that i don't like at all
no not at all so hopefully we continue
to get more information we need more
information
things like this need to be explained
yeah exactly okay before we get into our
next story i want to let you know that
today's episode is also brought to you
by the pill club life is stressful
enough access to health care shouldn't
be luckily getting birth control is one
less thing you have to worry about with
the pill club you'll never have to make
a trip to the doctor or wait in line at
the pharmacy ever again they provide
access to care from the comfort of your
home and delivery to your door in
discreet packaging do you need to renew
your birth control prescription or you
want to switch your birth control maybe
try it for the first time whether you
know the brand you want or you want help
finding the best option the pill club
medical team has your back we're always
looking for ways to streamline our to-do
list and whether you know it's delivery
for dinner or ordering our stuff online
why should getting birth control be any
different with the pill club they make
it easy to get your birth control
without scheduling a trip to the
doctor's office or going to the pharmacy
in person
the pill club carries over 120 fda
approved brands most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as nine dollars per month without
insurance the pill club delivers birth
control to your door for free in
discreet packaging right now when you go
to the pillclub.com
toast the pill club is offering a 10
donation to bedsider.org for every
morning toast listener who becomes a
patient your doc your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through bedsider.org
that's thepillclub.com toast to get your
first birth control care package and
donate to help more women in need of
affordable birth control remember the
pill club.com toast you must use the
link to make a donation
okay our next story is some crazy couple
news
john mulaney and olivia munn's romance
faces uncertainty amid pregnancy oh
she's pregnant she's pregnant oh i
didn't know that yeah so an unknown
future john melanie and olivia munn are
expecting their first child together
amid a whirlwind romance but an insider
tells us weekly that their relationship
they just faces much uncertainty also
there was like rumors swirling you know
blind items on jumois that very much
made it seem as though it's this couple
that has broken up
amid her pregnancy that has already been
you know much highly talked about
because of the timeline are you familiar
with the timeline no are you familiar
with john mullaney yes are you a fan
uh
i've seen bits and pieces of stand-ups
that i've liked okay i'm not gonna he's
not like my favorite by any means okay
that's true but i think he's a i think
he's a solid mid-tier comedian okay cool
so he was married
last this time last year
and then he got separated divorced etc
but they didn't announce the divorce
until
five months ago oh and then
a month ago we found out that olivia
munn and john where two maybe it was two
months ago we found out they're dating a
month ago we find out she's pregnant oh
he was engaged to a different woman he
was married to a different woman
and now olivia munn is pregnant and the
timeline
goes to show allegedly
that she
was pregnant before they announced their
divorce so i think they were definitely
divorced before they announced it
but there's a bit of sure
weird crossover uh-huh and and so they
were putting it all like on the line for
you know this new relationship i think
you know people have definitely
had questions and now they're not
together potentially potentially they're
not together
i don't know i mean us weekly is saying
they're
having some bumpy road i think doom you
know dumas allegedly says that they're
done so who's do more
is like that instagram account that
writes you probably don't know it but
like they write blind items about
celebrities pretty much like anyone can
write in and like say something that
they saw or they know and dumas will
post it it's an imperfect formula but
sometimes you get some good teeth my
brain's all in impeachment so it sounds
like the drudge report
interesting it's like it reminds me of
empty do you remember nt it's like the
same thing but it's like the instagram
version as opposed to a website got it
well sad for the baby
yeah i mean this is just another dip on
the wild roller coaster that is their
relationship i feel like olivia munn
wasn't who else was she recently dating
did she date aaron rodgers she was
dating aaron rodgers for a while and
then she was potentially dating casey
musgrave's ex but that's just like based
on some social media comments
um but yeah aaron rodgers was a big one
cool and they say like she was
responsible for him not talking to his
family but they've been broken up for
years and he still doesn't talk to his
family so i don't think that's fair to
put that on her same
now aaron rodgers is really happy
is he he's with shailene woodley
who's that
big little eyes yes yes yes yeah how do
you feel about them
i love aaron rodgers you do yeah
i do i think he's unbelievable at
football okay and i think that
everything that sort of surrounds him
like i don't know everybody's
like should sort of bend the knee to him
when it comes to football okay there's a
lot of like other drama i don't know
i've heard of the drama within football
because they didn't they didn't recruit
the players he needed instead they got
another quarterback and he was insulted
no but it's like
you're you're the star player mm-hmm you
want to be involved in
the team yeah you've dedicated your life
to an organization
like it makes perfect sense yeah he also
uh do you know what the match is
no it's like a golf tournament that they
put on tv with like celebrities so
uh phil mickelson and aaron rodgers
versus
tom brady
and
was it tiger
in the first one whatever aaron rodgers
was great at goth
fun fact fun fact yeah really good
that's pretty cool yeah it was it's
pretty cool so anyways um
concerned about john midlaney and olivia
munn i mean hopefully we get more info
soon but this doesn't sound that's not
the news that you want to hear when
she's like
i guess now
six seven months pregnant it's gotta be
very stressful for her yeah yeah you
shouldn't have any stresses and i think
it's been stressful also like just
i don't think their relationship was
received very well
by the world because of the timeline
also he had said when he was married
that he didn't want kids so they like he
was on comedians and cars and he said
that and then he gets divorced and the
next day like olivia oh so then it must
have been
adultery
i don't know i don't know because like
they might have been i only use that
term because i know he's a devout
christian
is he yeah
big time but then he you're alleging he
committed adultery adultery
which i'm just saying i don't know i
just i think that maybe
i think maybe they were divorced like
way before and separated way before
they announced it could have even been
six months
but it's just it doesn't say right it's
hard for the public to digest
i'm not gonna digest it okay it's not
digestible no no i don't think so
well are you ready for our fifth and
final story i'm ready
are you ready oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah where's my clacker okay
give us your best i know just put your
heart into it okay okay
okay it's the final story
[Music]
it's not the best i got but i will
record a video another time
the mickey that was what you have to do
at mickey that's what i was trying to
think of because we we took requests
some people said punk opera someone said
in mickey mouse clubhouse style
i know like okay i'm gonna try give it
to for mickey
meesker muskar micky
[Music]
[Music]
hot dog hot dog hot diggity
clubhouse is a wonderful show it [ __ ]
slaps and mickey and the game goes so
hard they leave it all out there in the
clubhouse in the gang
yeah yeah like when they're doing that
hot dog dance at the end like they're
[ __ ]
giving us everything oh yeah and mickey
gives us the most he puts everything on
his back he really does it's really
incred like it's actually a remarkable
show we've spoken about before but also
it's like every episode he's a farmer
he's a pilot like he's an entrepreneur
he wears all of these hats and he does
it incredibly well he does
he's i mean i understand why the kids
look up to him oh yeah mickey is a jack
of all trades he's a jack of all trades
he's a remarkable man
our fifth and final story is that
another musical family just like us
the jonas brothers are starring in
netflix's first ever family roast nick
joe and kevin are set to star in jonas
brothers family roast a one-hour comedy
special premiering globally on netflix
on november 23rd jonas brothers family
roast is a one-of-a-kind comedy special
of epic proportions that celebrates the
universal truth that no one can get
under your skin quite like your own
family the streaming service announced
in a press release on monday you'll see
the multi-platinum global superstars the
jonas brothers like you've never seen
them before through sketches songs games
and special guests all to give them a
roasting they'll never forget so keenan
thompson is hosting the roast and there
will also be special guest appearances
from
pete davidson niall horan gabriel
iglesias john legend lily singh and jack
whitehall this is netflix's first ever
family roast and it does beg the
question will it be the last or is this
something that we're going to be
watching all the time now i love that
they're just like branding it as a
family roast as if they're not just
completely ripping off comedy central's
roasts that have been going on for 20
years the exact same thing you think so
now if they want to call it the family
roast where like they're roasting three
people instead of one
yeah it's the same thing well up until
all those guests toast you know i
thought it was like maybe the jonas
brothers just like sitting around
ripping each other and like playing like
old family clips and stuff
but and it's also like right in time for
thanksgiving so it's probably like
something you can watch with your family
but now like if pete davidson's there
yeah it's a roast they're roasting them
they're roasted
yeah
interesting though
well you know what honestly if it's like
a comedy central style roast that does
sound far more interesting so much more
than the brothers sitting around
roasting each other no it's much better
i'm just saying that format does exist
yes yes but i am still excited for it i
love a good roast
the comedy centrals are fantastic and i
am happy that it's not just the jonas
brothers sitting around
uh roasting each other yeah because i
was thinking to myself like netflix gave
that a comedy special yeah where is girl
with no jobs comedy special if you're
gonna give it to like the jonas brothers
like picking their nose and talking to
them no through sketches songs and games
yeah that can happen i don't want to see
the jonas brothers play games no i don't
but
if pete davidson actually you know
pete is a tough one for me sometimes
he's so funny sometimes he just isn't
you know i guess we can't always be on
our game
yeah
i i think i like him i like him i take
back whatever but the other people are
not comedians like so it's actually i
feel like it's going to be a light roast
nile horn you know who that is
yeah gabriel iglesias i don't know that
is john legend
lily singh is a a comedian yeah and jack
whitehall willie is a comedian well yeah
because she was she came up like on
youtube doing like comedy videos i
didn't know they were commenting videos
she had a late late late night show that
i don't remember and it was you know how
could i forget that show those shows are
comedy technically yeah they i mean
so i think she's a comedian yeah
that's my analysis i wonder if she
thinks she's a comedian i think she
thinks she's a comedian okay so that's
fun yeah interesting when you first read
the list i didn't think about how not
funny the majority of that was not funny
at all wow
so
interesting yeah i think it's going to
be very like family-friendly yeah who's
the first person that you said
see pete davidson i bet you they went to
everybody that does comedy central
roasts and pete was the only one who
said yes maybe he's friends with the
boys that's why like maybe they asked
him
oh you think it was them asking for
their own roasters maybe interesting
cool
yeah it should be interesting i mean
we'll see if
we'll see if we watch it
we'll definitely watch it you think i
feel like so many times on the show we
talk about like upcoming content
that we're excited about that we just
like when it actually drops we're like
nah i love i love a good roast yeah
they're funny i think they're important
i think it's important to be
self-deprecating and just laugh at
yourself and it's important for the
youth to see that as well from their
highest stars
i just hope that they really dig in
okay i don't know if they will i don't
think they're going to dig in but
i think we'll get light roast yeah light
roast um
also i was just going to say you should
make a roast and watch the roast oh yeah
do you watch snl this weekend
uh zach showed me like a couple of clips
he sent me one clip they did an annie
spoof it was cute okay so here's my
thoughts like it was so well done in
terms of like the song and you know
everything was going really well but
like the concept itself just like wasn't
funny enough agreed completely agreed
you know and i really wanted it it was
close like usually sometimes the concept
is good the execution is trash the
execution was good the concept was trash
that like
daddy
has like humans yeah like he has like a
guy who like does shady [ __ ] for him and
it turns out he like eats humans it's
just like a bad it's bad it was bad yeah
like it would have been there's i don't
know i don't know what would have been
funny are you familiar with um annie
live that's dropping in december and
you're familiar with the cast yeah and
how are you feeling about it i love
annie in general yeah anything that
anything annie i mean she's a queen yeah
and he's a queen i love annie and
claudia and i are excited about annie
lives maybe we'll all watch together i
think for uh in honor of annie live you
need to get a perm
stop i think you do okay
okay um
now we are going to get into our tv
recap we both watched the same stuff
this weekend and we're going to talk
about it but i must let you know our tv
recap is brought to you by bowling
branch which is so perfect because i
spent the whole weekend in bed watching
tv in my bowling branch sheets that are
so damn comfortable no one wants to cut
corners on what's important and a few
things few things matter more than a
good night's sleep bowling branches
signature sheets feel so soft and light
you'll you'll forget you're not actually
sleeping on a cloud and they're
sustainably made for uncompromising
quality from field to factory if you
dream of comfortable sheets at a price
that won't keep you up at night look no
further than bull and branch i actually
just ordered a new set
of bolon brand sheets because weirdly i
was like always washing and putting on
the same ones and i was like you know
what i need a second i need a second set
so i just got fresh bowl and brand
sheets there everything of this sort
they're the perfect thing you need for a
great night's sleep the signature hem
sheets from bowling branch our best
seller for a reason they have buttery
soft lightweight organic cotton and a
classic satin weave for sheets that get
softer over time not too hot not too
cold the perfect year-round sheets for
most sleepers bowling brand's signature
sheets come in seven beautiful colors in
all sizes from twin up to california
king made to a higher standard 100 organ
cotton ethical production and thoughtful
attention to detail experience the best
sheets you've ever felt at bowlin branch
dot com get 15 percent off your first
set of sheets when used promo code toast
at checkout that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast and yes
when i ordered a new set i used
permacotos and it was
wonderfully satisfying so get your
bowling branch get your sheets right so
you can watch great tv in bed
you deliver a nice ad read thank you so
much it is such a nice compliment that's
true it's like i really do i hear the
products and i'm thinking you know i'm
going to go home later and i'm going to
research bowl and bread you know what
i'm at the end of the day that's what an
ad read is i'm pretty sure you can try
to look it up bowling brand sheets on
your bed you wouldn't know but that's a
because that's a claudia department true
so you you actually are sleeping in
bowling branch you didn't even know it
they're comfy sheets they're comfy
sheets comfy sheets okay duvet cover
though i need a new duvet cover
we are in what we thought it was it was
great it was uh
what is it what's the material
it's a it's not satin weave
no it's it's it's a little bit stiff
uh
linen linen linen in october linen in
general i loved linen we loved it for a
minute we're like ooh linen and now it's
just like it's a summery fabric no but
it's also it's heavy you need it's not
supposed to be heavy yeah you need to
we're in a heavy linen you need satine
weave is that a part of bowling bridge
yeah sateen weave yeah also it's very
nice that you've complimented me on my
ad delivery skills because usually
claudia does them so i'm putting on a
new hat today well it was a great read
thank you very much okay let's get into
our tv recap first up let's talk about
what happened brittany murphy the
brittany murphy documentary two parts on
hbo max two hours total can we start off
with the title okay what is that title i
was thinking about the title too like
are they looking for
like did they forget to put in the word
two like what happened to brittany
murphy i i had the same thought and i
think that you know they could have done
that and that would have been you know a
very obvious title you know what
happened to brittany murphy here's two
hours worth of looking at it
but i think they're also the title begs
the question like we're asking brittany
murphy what happened okay you know
because it's like really
especially after watching this like only
she knows but still what happened
brittany murphy
no but it should have been hey britney
what happened
yeah what happened comma britney murphy
is like a really
it's annoying well you know what i think
it's it's thought-provoking we're
talking about it because of how dumb it
is okay and the documentary was made
with such integrity i thought it was a
wonderful doc yeah and the title just
was not it for me okay i thought that
the title was definitely curious
and i didn't mind it okay cool but i
understand why you did
so
they get into the story so britney
murphy passed away in december 2009
and the cause was listed and you know
even still is after all the
investigation pneumonia plus anemia
plus
a lot of prescription pills in her
system equals disaster
and they sort of take us on the journey
of her career and you know where she
might have been at mentally
when she met her husband simon jack you
know in the three years that they were
married and you know in the weeks
leading up to her
eventual death and then post her death
how he and her mom handled everything
and then six months after she died
he died too in
the sit in a very similar way
so i was going through all the different
feelings and i think that that's what
they wanted you to feel like first you
know you're confused as to how a
healthy 32 year old woman dies of
pneumonia then you start to
get you know and they showed all those
youtubers doing their makeup by the way
and but like where did they find these
youtubers i think they wanted to show
how without having like a narrator tell
you they wanted to show how people have
gotten really
caught up in and and carried away with
conspiracy theories about what happened
to brittany murphy like every like
you know they could have used i think at
the time it was 2009 so like youtube was
a good forum for fans who were
questioning today it might have been you
know podcast audio
but they were just trying to capture how
her fans felt like and also all the
different conspiracies that were out
there no i got it just the youtubers
that they picked seemed rather janky but
what was like
what was with the trend of like we're
going to talk about the brittany murphy
case while i do my makeup
and then like when they showed the clips
like at certain points they like you
know we're at a weird stage of makeup
where they have like no
in on their face and it was it was very
weird to watch and also like it's not
like those are
youtubers i've ever seen so it's not
like everybody's saying this no no i
think they just used it as a way to
narrate what people the regular folk
might have been thinking it was a cool
idea yes
yeah yeah so
it was a journey for me because
obviously you know we we know surface
level like brittany murphy passed away
far too young under some
curious circumstances but i really never
knew too much about it and i think
everybody knew sort of her husband was
this
seedy kind of guy
and then i didn't even realize like when
they went on larry king after britney
died i i never i didn't hadn't seen that
with those photos that they took the mom
and the husband
i never saw like i didn't even know
because i was talking to zack after i
was like explaining the documentary he's
like and didn't the mom and the husband
like get together i was like no but they
definitely made people think that they
did yeah but then from the documentary i
don't think that they were like that
they plotted to no to kill brittany no
they didn't i think it was just
deep negligence control like and
especially after talking hearing from
simon's
other girlfriend the one who who had his
baby and she explains like what she went
through and how really if her friend
didn't show up unannounced like she
might have been dead also so to see his
pattern
it's like this control that he
and his obsession with anorexia and i
guess also like the even the photography
in the house they're just like
dark
art
it was weird it was it was weird and it
was really dark and i think
you know
it's i mean one of my favorite people
who spoke in the documentary was kathy
and jamie yep
and i mean i thought she did just such a
great job in general when she said why
didn't i just like go and bang down her
door
and i think i was reading some of the
toasters um
reviews on it as well and so many people
were just like why didn't like she where
were her friends like some but she they
pushed everyone out you know if you
tried to say something you got cut off
too
so
it's like
i don't know how it could have been any
different
where we differ in opinion is that i
really don't think that it was just
negligence because
i think that he's a really really shady
character no i think but it was like
intentional negligence i think he killed
her because i'm sure
you think he intentionally killed her i
think that he was intentionally getting
her as sick as possible because the
sicker she got the more in control he
was yes and then at some point when
everybody started pointing fingers at
him that he killed her
that's when he decided to kill himself
yes because i don't think that
it's a coincidence that it's both
pneumonia
i think that we were talking about this
before
that yeah he liked when his girls were
anorexic and he would push them towards
that and that's why she was anemic and
that's why she was so sick and that's
why the combination of the pills the
anemia all this stuff gave her pneumonia
but him dying of pneumonia when he's 900
pounds
and clearly well-fed
and uh was no longer in that lifestyle
because he was with
brittany's mom
like britney's mom didn't die yeah like
i think that it's pretty clear to me
that
he's the one who killed her also simon's
mom i understand that you want to
protect your son i totally get it but
like her being just like so
defensive yeah was very in in really
poor taste yeah uh
and i again i understand lost a son it's
horrible but
your son goes around talking about how
he's a billionaire lying to his ex-wife
that he had cancer so that she'd sleep
with him and have a child right
yeah like clearly you have a bad son and
you can at least acknowledge
the role that he played in killing a
very happy britney murphy
the one caveat that i'll say to that is
that hollywood also let brittany murphy
down
and move her towards a place where
someone like a simon could come in so
easily and [ __ ] her up yeah like she was
like they showed that was probably my
favorite part about the doc was
really showing like they had all these
testimonials about how happy she was
yeah how she was like the light in every
room and then all of a sudden she wanted
bigger roles and they said that she was
too fat and then she got skinnier and
skinnier and skinnier and then in comes
mr con man
ready to pounce yeah she was just ripe
she was ripe from hollywood to be taken
advantage of by him but i do think that
he
uh
whether or not the intent was her to die
the intent was to make her as sick as
possible so that she needed him yes i
agree with that but i also think you
know he became her agent her manager
hairstyle publicist hairstylist makeup
artist and i'm sure when she starts
feeling sick he's also her doctor for
sure and he's giving her you know all
these prescription medicine
and
because of the control like his
obsession with control he's not going to
call for help when he won't even you
know let someone else do her makeup yep
so it's all make like congress and so at
the beginning of the documentary it's
like how does a 32 year old
healthy woman pass away from pneumonia
by the end of the documentary it's like
given everything that was going on in
that house how could she not have died
you know but it's also how was the cause
of death pneumonia i mean it makes sense
i get it it's like when you're
when your immune system is that defeated
you can die from anything yeah but just
a terrible terrible story because she
i also just forgot all of the movies
that she was in i know i'm like and i
didn't realize how her career like
really went
and how easily he ruined it and they
made it make perfect perfect sense it's
like he's her agent manager etc and
nobody wants to [ __ ] work with him so
she has to take direct to dvd movies so
sad so sad and she was so
so talented also i thought one of the um
maybe it was the
one of the people who spoke said
something which was that you know she
didn't go to high school she was like
just doing education on set if that and
it's like in junior high and high
schools like where you learn
tells about people you know you
experience betrayal love like all of
these emotions where you learn how to
like read people whether this is a good
person bad person average etc and so she
had none of those
defenses
and just welcomed anyone into her life
so again it's just like the perfect
storm of how someone like this could
come in and especially after like two
engagements and breaking up with ashton
kutcher and like she just was looking
for love
and
you know simon was able to cloak his
his nefariousness
as love
crazy crazy so and the piece that just
like she stole all of her money i know
that was just like the icing on the cake
like the mom is ready to sell the jewels
so that she hasn't it's all fake what
did he spend the money on
um
i probably keeping up his personal
appearance of like to everybody else he
was that billionaire yeah he like he
probably kept up appearances he probably
sent money to his kids yeah um
he probably sent money to his ex-wife to
keep her quiet
like the one that was on screen yeah
that was the saddest story why did he
get her pregnant
what was the point i don't know like why
again to control her i don't know
he uses sick such a crazy guy i also
didn't realize that he died so soon
after her like i was wondering if he was
going to show up in the documentary i
didn't know he was already and neither
did i
and brittany's mom is alive and just
nowhere to be found yeah
she's probably
destroyed yeah because it's as much her
fault
as it is britney's that he was able to
make that push into her life
yeah but i mean they just like were not
like the whole doc show like explains
that brittany and her mom were best
friends yeah
brittany's mom i think lived with them
yeah she did but they're they're just
like these two like trusting loving
people like looking for totally love you
know they just worked completely
completely
conned found yeah
so that was
that was eye opening i'm glad that we
watched that great great idea to do
toast movie of the week it was great
and then curb
you know what's so funny like every
weekend sometimes i watch
it like randomly it's just out of
coincidence everything i watch is on the
same platform so this was a very hbo max
weekend for me because i watched curb
britney murphy and succession all
weekend whereas like last weekend i felt
like i was watching hulu all anyways
curb premiered last night eleventh
season larry's back after he said that
tenth season was the end but obviously
he had to come back because of kovid you
know if anyone's going to talk about
cove but it's got to be larry yep but
it wasn't about kovid so here's what one
piece was one piece was but before i
before it premiered i was like
talking about it was zach we were both
so excited and i was like it's just
going to be crazy everything else every
other show that i've watched is just
skipping over covid like there's no like
it's not reflective of even the world
that we live in right now where it's
like you know you where you're going
into a restaurant on a date you wear
your mask and then you take it off and
then you put it back on and then you
wear it in the uber it's like it's
completely it's 2019 every show like
nobody wants to show it because nobody
wants to [ __ ] watch it like yep so i
was like it's gonna be interesting to
watch a show that's really covet centric
because
up until now like i would have thought i
don't want to watch it but i do want to
see larry's take on it because even
before kovit he's a germaphobe he has
purell at the latte larry's like the
tables are socially distanced like he's
just that guy
but then it wasn't about that at all
which was like fine because i wasn't
even sure i wanted like that that would
be interesting television but it's like
so why did he come back
probably because he had more to give i
mean larry's so funny so funny i thought
this episode had a lot of great moments
i don't think it was a great episode
overall
yeah that was the other thing i i
didn't love it it wasn't it felt like
now the some of the plot lines just felt
weak and every episode of curb is like a
perfect nugget circuitous the circle is
complete the last you know
joke it just brings it back to the first
and it's like
that didn't happen at all it didn't
happen at all it was there were too many
usually it's like larry's got a few
juggling a few things two or three
things that in the end all sort of come
back to each other nothing
he's joining he
he's got like seven things he's juggling
nothing really
what came full circle
the
thing about the extortion with the fence
in the pool it's like if someone's
burglarizing your house
and they're committing a crime what
happened is say they you know trip down
the stairs they can't sue you no like
it's it was a funny like the funniest
part about that piece is
of course you need a fence and like
nobody has a fence yeah but like i get
that like that part was funny the idea
of it i agree that the extortion and him
going to the guy's taco place and having
to cast his daughter was like it was
just like bizarre yeah there was but
there were so many things going on think
about like so there's that storyline
there's also the storyline of the guy
who owes him money that that was by far
the funniest plot line the the jeweler
with dementia yeah was a great plot line
then and then
he just [ __ ] takes care of him
anything with susie susie is just pure
gold susie really is pure gold then also
there was the walking into the
glass class door which to me was the
funniest plot line because it's like
there are things like that in life where
it's like people just look at you
differently after sure you're
like
just no longer
the very person that you were before no
it was hysterical it was hysterical yeah
it was
and like i'm excited to see
um
oh what the [ __ ] is his name
yeah he lives with larry no my favorite
ugh
who explain lives with larry the only
guy that loves larry um
you're killing me i know
stop i know all right whatever it'll
come to me because i literally love him
i can't believe i'm blanking but i'm
excited to see him go on a trip with
that woman oh my god did he like casted
for his free vacation i hope he found
true love
with her because they seem like
okay i'm sorry leon leon yes thank you
yeah so that'll be funny for next
episode uh i thought that the idea again
like
there are some
larry
concepts that are great as just
one-liners but that don't belong as full
scenes like the idea of
having a funeral when you're still alive
is a funny line it's like oh like all
your friends gather and like say such
nice things about you and you're dead
yes but like i definitely wouldn't have
made it a scene
yeah also but i just want to say like
i don't know if anybody is going to
remember this alongside me but there
used to be a show on the wb
when we were like
in the 90s
and it's called i think it's called
maybe it's me and the grandma
hosts her own funeral before because she
was like the same idea you know why
should everybody have this party
with when i'm not here blah blah blah so
like the whole time it was just like
maybe it's me was living run free in my
mind and i was like i've seen this
before interesting so if anybody
remembers that episode
please just reach out to me so that we
can be simpatico and then also at the
end larry opens the coved hoarding
closet
and
it's a it's funny
but the reactions were not funny like
jon hamm like literally freaking out
was
again but i you know
larry's also so smart maybe it was just
so satirical like again in the other
direction that he was
oh he was making fun of the people that
are so angry at covert orders yeah like
he really he is so calculated people
showed up to a living funeral
but they're going to be outraged
by a closet of purell yeah outraged
yeah you know you never really know
where what larry's thinking and that's
why i think he is just
so amazing i didn't love this episode
but i will obviously watch every episode
this season me too
the second you strike a gold episode
they're just there's just nothing better
yeah and a perfect curb episode but i
agree with you there are a lot of plot
lines that never found a home and the
best part about curb is it's always full
circle every episode yeah so so that's
that was my take but of course i'm going
to watch the whole season glad that it's
back for whatever reason compelled him
even if we're not going to do a whole
coveted season which i wasn't even
looking forward to i was just that's
what i was expecting
um i'm here for regardless same cool
cool glad we're on the same page glad we
sussed that out oh yeah
okay well i'm gonna let you go thank you
so much for filling in these past three
days everyone has totally loved your
presents claudia will be back tomorrow
so it'll be business as usual and i just
want to let you guys know so you can
start getting excited friday is our
toast to ween episode claudia and i you
know we go out we go all out on the show
for halloween
and we have some big plans for this
friday so i'm really excited you know
gotta gotta get in the zone
but i think it's gonna be great so
friday toast to wean
we'll see you there see you tomorrow
back with claude ben thank you so much
for joining us of course thank you for
having me this was wonderful and i will
be
back very soon yes on the morning toast
the millennium morning show where we
deliver the past five stories every
monday through friday
around 10 30 um
etc etc sorry
if you made it this far like claudia
usually does the wrap up and i just yeah
all social channels yeah you guys if you
if you're watching this if you're
hearing this you know
now if you've made it this far into the
episode you are a member of society
season two so please go comment on the
picture of me and ben an emoji of
what did we talk about today a lot yeah
we did
um
maybe flames emoji for the roast
flames i love the flames flames flames
we'll see you tomorrow goodbye bye guys
you